[Music]
so good afternoon everybody my name is
Paul Nash and I manage the product team
for Google compute engine so today is an
update from last year's talk which was
called saving money on compute engine so
this year it is saving more money on
compute engine right there so just out
of curiosity how many of you might have
seen that talk either online or last
year even by show of hands excellent
good all my jokes are good then but to
get a little sense of what we're gonna
do here I'm gonna show you all the
different ways that we have where you
can save more money on compute engine
apart from the fact that all of you are
new how many of you are currently Google
customers that are using either GCE or a
product that you believe runs on compute
engine show of hands
okay great awesome thank you so now a
little bit of a quiz sorry it's after
lunch I did request the comfortable
chairs for you please don't fall asleep
but I won't take it personally if you do
but I have a little bit of audience
participation just to get you thinking
about the space so this is gonna be like
a game on prices right called that's too
much I believe what I'd like you to do
is raise your hands and keep them up if
you believe that on average customers
waste at least 10% of their spend on
compute engine 10% okay so if you think
it's at least 10% but not more than 15%
put your hands down if you think it's
15% or more keep your hands up okay
what about 20% 30% 40% yeah so it turns
out it's about 35% now this particular
stack comes to us from right scale they
do a broad survey of cloud adopters
every year and the number that they
actually measure customers they're
working with is 35% interestingly it
turns out that the customers
survey think the number is 30% so
they're already pretty pessimistic about
their efficiency but then they're not
even as pessimistic as reality so it
shouldn't be any surprise then that
those customers also say that 76% of
them that spend control is one of their
challenges about a third of those say
that it's one of their most significant
challenges and over half of them say
that it's their top focus for 2018 so
presumably some of those reasons might
be why you're here today and so we're
going to talk about some of the things
that you can take advantage of on
compute engine to address that concern
so before I go any further
usually this light comes at the end but
this is an important enough topic
obviously we put a lot of effort into
making sure that we have a lot of great
content for you here at cloud next over
the coming days and so I wanted to call
out some of the other great
presentations that you can either see
here or catch on YouTube that go into
some in more detail on some of the tools
and techniques that are outside compute
engines features itself but within our
billing support systems that you can use
to to help you with this problem and
I'll give it a little preview of some of
those at the end
so since food is probably on minds of a
lot of people here or maybe not because
you've just ate I thought I would keep
this a little bit light I have a little
bit of a metaphor running through as if
this were a cooking show and I'm gonna
teach you how to cook up an efficient
cloud bill so bear with me I won't over
stretch the metaphor too much hopefully
but I'm gonna start with sharing some
basic ideas about cooking your bill and
then move on to some of the ingredients
that you can play with to get the best
outcome and then I'll talk about some
recipes that you should try at home
and then we have some gadgets at the end
so chopping onions that's kind of where
most people start for cooking that's a
good thing to learn so what are some of
the basic ideas about cost management
that you should be thinking about as
you're looking about how you use compute
engine well so first of all we're
working on pricing innovations and when
we're thinking about what do we want to
do
kind of keep three core principles in
mind and those are the ones you see here
it should be simple it should be
flexible and it should be fair so those
are kind of big words and they can mean
a lot of different things I'm gonna tell
you what they mean to me and to our team
when we're when we're working on these
things and we think that these are the
ideals that represent what customers
tell us they would like to have and so
we really try to keep those in mind so
that guy was pretty smart he had a good
idea simple is nice to say but obviously
cloud is a very complicated space so
what does it mean to have a very simple
approach to pricing in a complex space
it doesn't mean everything is exactly
the same price it doesn't mean there's
not any dials or knobs you can optimize
what it should mean is that the concepts
are simple that it's easy for you as a
customer to understand how it works how
changes would happen if you make changes
to your usage and then it all kind of
makes sense you don't have to have a PhD
in economics a PhD in physics or a team
of people figuring out how this works
you can kind of hold it in your head
that's that's the idea of simple that
we're going for so like I said simple to
understand simple to use but powerful
enough to meet your needs and you have a
lot of complex needs as a set of
customers there's a lot of different use
cases and so we want to be able to
capture those and make sure that what
you're getting works for your situation
but no rocket science and definitely not
hidden costs so then what it's flexible
mean well like I said across our
customer base there's a very broad set
of different use cases not all
businesses are alike not all teams are
thinking about spending in the same way
that might be because the finance
department or the IT division or whoever
thinks about how this money is spent
might have a different approach to how
the controls work within that company it
might be that you're a start-up and the
finance department is Joe or Sally and
it's their credit card or it might be a
much more complex situation and we have
another talk actually and it talks about
how you could scale that whole that
whole challenge also your knees are
going to change over time so something
that you bought
18 months ago or signed up for three
years on if it's not flexible enough
it's not going to meet your needs by the
end of your time so we think a lot about
that and what that really boils down to
in our product is that you should be
able to pay for what you need not
anything more and you shouldn't have
regrets when those things do change or
feel like you can't make changes because
then you wouldn't be efficient with your
spend and finally fair so I have a bunch
I have three small kids in my
five-year-old I'm sure you know the
phrase but that's not fair so we're
working a lot on what the word fair
means it doesn't mean what he thinks it
means what it means in this context is
what works for Google works for you
so Moore's law happens prices go down
for our components performance goes up
you should see that reflected just as if
you were buying the machines yourself
you should always be getting a great
price and you should always be getting a
great value so a lot of times we talk
about price performance not just price
that also has led to some of the
innovative features that we've brought
out such as automatic discounts you
don't have to ask us or learn the secret
trip to know how to use the discount it
just happens we think that's a pretty
cool innovation that is fair if it's
more efficient for us to run we should
give you some of that back as a discount
it also has led to us building tools
like right sizing recommendations which
is if you're overspending we will
actually say hey you're overspending you
should stop doing that that's a little
counterintuitive for a for-profit
company right we're telling you to spend
less with us but we believe that that is
the fair and right thing to do and that
either you will use that somewhere else
for something that is valuable to you or
we will sell it to another customer and
we're happy either way and then finally
we want to give you smart tools and the
data that you need to be able to monitor
and control it so that there's no
questions about what you're spending
that's what we think fair means okay so
some terminology different people are at
different places but I want to highlight
a few things that we have customer
conversations with quite frequently and
the first one is what's a core what's a
BCP
what's a physical core oh it's a virtual
core right so on the left is a somewhat
older generation x86 CPU and if you
squint you can see here there are four
what I call physical cores actual
execution units that have all of their
stuff duplicated it's actually a mirror
image and there's four of those on there
so a lot of times a customer will come
to us and say well I have a four core
machine if you bought this processor it
would be called a quad core Intel CPU
but there's a technology called
hyper-threading which I'm sure many of
you are familiar with which essentially
allows each of those cores to run two
different paths of execution at the same
time
so in cloud those are commonly exposed
of as what we'd call a virtual core
independently or a V core or a V CPU so
it's kind of a little something like
that so that's a four core processor if
we were selling that as a VM which we
wouldn't do because that's not enough
course to put in a server but if we were
selling that that would be an eight V
CPU machine and we would sell an 8 V CPU
VM on it seems obvious perhaps but the
difference is 2 X right so if you're
analyzing your costs incorrectly
thinking about what you need the
difference can be significant and so
when we're having calm conversations
with customers about what size their VM
should be and how that scales in
particular if they're migrating
something from an on-prem environment
this is a topic that comes up very often
so I want to highlight it here so count
those cores carefully but the thing is
our hardware might be newer than what
you have the performance might be
different your software may or may not
be clock rate or thread sensitive so
it's not always quite as straightforward
as 2x and we'll talk a little bit later
about why it's important to measure that
but it is important to look at this now
the other thing to keep in mind is that
you may have software licenses for
example Microsoft licenses either for
Windows Server for sequel server tend to
measure in terms of physical cores
sometimes when you move to cloud they
decide to use that same license to apply
to a virtual core
can change your costs so it's another
thing to be aware of also I want to talk
about analyzing your needs so looking
across clouds for example list prices
are not exactly the same the machines
are not necessarily the same the way
that you pay is not necessarily the same
you're not actually likely to pay list
price unless you're doing a very unusual
usage pattern but the list price is
still are not the same so if that's
where you start your analysis you're
already not quite looking at it the way
it's going to show up on your bill you
need to understand how they're different
clouds discount differently and what
your usage pattern is going to look like
so this kind of leads to a similar tip
which is think about your analysis try
to come as close as you can to modeling
what your usage is really going to look
like a lot of times a proof-of-concept
use case can help with this so finally
that that broad idea of understanding
what your usage is what are the
underlying trends how peaky or spiky is
your workload gonna be and then once you
understand that it's important to also
understand that the true utilization
what I'll call true utilization is not
actually how many cores you've deployed
if they're all idle you're not getting
any value out of those right and so the
ROI on those you could call zero you're
paying for something you're not using I
would say it's actually negative because
it's still burning power and so when
you're thinking about comparing one
situation to another it's important to
keep that in mind finally TCO that's not
usually what it stands for but it's a
very confusing topic so that's what I'm
gonna call it today so customers often
times when they're calculating their
internal TCO this turns into a big
conversation about what have they
included what have they not included the
point that I want to make here though is
that even once you get that whole
financial analysis right you're kind of
not done because your on-prem
configuration is a much longer timeframe
environment right so from your finance
department you'll hear while our TCO is
X dollars or X cents per core hour and
that's on a machine that maybe has a
three year or a five year depreciation
schedule depending on your refresh but
guess what that hardware is out of date
in 18 months so you have it for another
year and a half to three and a half year
and that's what you get on you're not
getting performance upgrades you may not
have other accelerators that you can
plug into it you may not be able to
upgrade your racks to have more power
you may not be able to change your
networking here you may not be able to
resize your discs by making a single
click so there's a lot of other
limitations and flexibility you lose in
that calculation and that doesn't always
show up in the actual dollars per watt
kind of calculation so it's important
consideration to keep in mind when
you're thinking about whether the prices
are apples to apples okay
so let's talk about some of the
ingredients that go into our cost saving
souffle if you will first of all the way
we think about it at Google is there's a
set of base resources pretty much
fundamentally a computer is a processing
unit and some RAM for data and then
there's some i/o that brings the data in
and out right so in a lot of places
where you might deploy that ratio of how
many V CPUs to how much gigabytes of RAM
is fixed or at least it's fixed among a
small set of options the problem with
that is it might not match your workload
so that's one aspect the second aspect
is what we would think of as the
attached resources things that you could
imagine you're plugging into a server in
reality they may already be there or
your VM is just going to be assigned to
a server that happens to have those
things and then you're gonna use them
when you need them but how do you think
about those are those essentially welded
into the VM that you need to buy or do
you get to choose dynamically or in a
very granular way what you need and then
pay for that so looking at that and
thinking about the problem that way and
thinking about having a decomposed
solution led us to looking at this idea
of alphabet letters and shapes and sizes
and z1 and x7 and all of this stuff and
the fact that those have these
pre-configured shapes of what you're
gonna get you're gonna get a certain V
CPU and RAM ratio you're gonna get
certain devices plugged in and the the
providers that do it that way are trying
to guess at what your use case is going
to be
they're doing one guess for a broad set
of customers and even within those use
cases things might be different so if
you want to use a bunch of nvidia gpus
you might have very different use cases
in very different patterns that mean you
need more CPU less CPU more RAM less RAM
so when you're thinking about cost you
need to think about the fact that it's
not just the dollars per hour cost of
that the um that pre-configured shape if
you're not using some of those resources
you're just paying for waste that you
don't need now it turns out that getting
this right and doing this in a
decomposed way is a really tricky
problem fortunately Google internally
uses a system called Borg to manage our
fleet and you've probably read a little
bit about that in the press maybe not
but that's how we managed our fleet for
over a decade and it's gotten very good
having flexible definition of what a job
uses and how many resources it needs and
it understands how to pack those things
together in an efficient way and compute
engine is built on top of that core
technology and it uses and leverages all
of that so for us having more flexible
definition of what a VM is was an easy
thing to do because we already had that
infrastructure there if you don't have
that infrastructure making everything
scale in a fixed size and ratcheting it
up by powers of two makes for a
relatively simple scheduling problem and
you can efficiently schedule the machine
the problem is any waste is the
customer's responsibility to pay for and
that's not what we wanted to end up with
in our design okay so what are some of
the things you can do with these
ingredients as it were on compute engine
to cook up some savings so kind of the
direction I've been leading with the
last couple slides is talking about
where we land it with custom machine
types so if you haven't seen this
feature before essentially the idea is
pick the ratio you want decide what you
want attached and you're done that's
what you pay for so we allow for any
increments of either from one's 1/v CPU
and then any multiple of two
up to the largest machine size that we
offer and RAM within a very broad ratio
of about 0.9 gigabytes to 6.5 gigabytes
per CPU so it's a ratio range that you
can tune in quarter gigabyte increments
so what that means is pretty much any
ratio you've you've got out there unless
it's fourteen to one sixteen to one on
RAM you can build your own custom
machine type that matches that ratio
exactly then you can pick how much
storage you want to attach to it you can
pick if you want local SSD attached to
it GPUs cloud TP use you can figure that
and then that's what you pay for and we
show you the prices of those individual
units so one of the things that we found
is that this is very helpful for
customers that are doing migrations
particularly from on-prem where in the
past processor manufacturers have made
machines that are six cores or
processors that are six cores 12 14 18
those aren't powers of two so if you're
actually looking to migrate an existing
application without many changes the
thing that might make the most sense is
to be able to size it into a VM that
exactly matches the same number of
resources and so this lets you do that
now we'll talk in a minute about whether
or not that's as far as you could go and
optimizing your spend but it's a
reasonable starting point and it helps
you already so if you thought about what
you do with migrating to a cloud that
didn't have that option
if you need 10 V CPUs and your only
option is one that has 16 you're already
60% over on the processing power so what
do you do you squeeze it down to 8 you
run 16 and hope it's okay
and just take the extra costs you don't
have to make that choice um go along
another thing that we see is for some
reason it's pretty strange we're not
really sure a lot of people run to
gigabytes per V CPU and we do actually
know the reason it's because that's a
ratio that exists on another cloud so
it's very easy to port over from that
perspective as well it's not a ratio
that we offer in our predefined types
but it is a common ratio so it can help
with that too if you just want to
minimize your changes
the nice thing about this is you can
also just optimize later you can start
where it makes sense and then if you
want to go spend some time maybe doing
some deep analysis of your application
later figure out exactly how much RAM
you really need just move the dial turn
down the ramp or maybe you're finding
that your server is sitting idle you
need fewer processors move the dial turn
down the processors and then quick
reboot and you're good to go we'd like
to get rid of the reboot but it turns
out a lot of guest operating systems
require it so maybe someday but wait
there's more
we'll actually help you with this so
last year we talked about right sizing
recommendations a little bit at that
time the feature was in beta it's now
generally available and this is actually
a snapshot of part of the cloud console
and so the feature is the right-hand
column
essentially we will watch your VM from
the outside without seeing any of the
data we look at the usage of CPU
utilization ram-paige utilization and we
can figure out how much you're leaving
idle and not using and after we've
watched that for a while we will make a
recommendation to you about a different
shape you could pick oftentimes it's
going to be a custom shape that will
allow you to save money we evaluate the
RAM and CPU dimensions separately so
essentially we're moving the knob for
you on custom machine types and then
it's with one click you can apply that
in addition we currently have in beta
the same capability but for managed
instance groups that are not Auto scaled
so auto scaling is is a little bit
harder problem because you're
essentially scaling horizontally so what
does it mean to resize any individual
instance is a trickier thing but we see
people use management since groups for
scenarios like a cluster of database
machines for example it's not a one that
changes in size but it might be that in
each of those individual machines are
oversized in one or both dimensions so
that capability is also there now one
caveat I'll mention and the other reason
why we do have the button for you to
click and confirm it is there are
outlier cases where you might actually
intentionally
want the machine to be over provisioned
an example I would give you is if you
have a certain latency target on say a
query response from a server you might
need the processor to be not fully
utilized so that you can hit that
reliably because when it starts to get
highly utilized then you're gonna get
more variants at your p90 or p99 so
there are some cases where that doesn't
necessarily make sense but for most
people this really helps you move the
dial on on what your spend is on how
much is wasted so another thing that we
do a little bit differently on google
cloud is to help you save automatically
as sustained use discounts so the core
idea here is very simple the more you
run the more you save up to 30% if you
run a VM for the whole month now it
turns out that's fairly straightforward
but that use case of you have to run it
for exactly the whole month might not
always happen in production scenarios
like let's say you need to reboot or
upgrade or you move to a different zone
or an instance type there are some of
those scenarios where it wouldn't be
fair if you refer to the principles for
us to say yep not sorry you don't get
the discount because you didn't meet
these type criteria the actual concept
here is if your usage is steady it's
more efficient for us to provide the
service for you and so in that case
we're very happy to give you a discount
so we came up with a concept called
inferred instances that actually looks
at all the different instances that are
the same size within a zone and looks at
their usage together and tries to create
the idea that these instances that were
really separate but running at different
times they could have all been run
together as one as if they were one and
it makes no difference to us so we
stacked that together and give you the
discount for the longest time span that
we can find the reason we can do this
incidentally is because for us this
billing discounts etc is just
essentially a big data problem it runs a
big MapReduce if any of you remember
what MapReduce is so it's that's what
Google calls a dupe and so it's very
simple for us to just have something
like this it's complex for
to process but simple for you to take
advantage of because turns out we like
big data problems at Google so with that
said one of the things that we saw we
could make better and you'll see I was
asked to put the road map note on the
top of the slide this is not available
quite yet but it's coming very soon
is we're moving from a model where
sustained use discount used to combine
only within a zone we're moving to a
model where it will combine across all
of the zones within a region and the
idea there is over time you know we've
made it clear that we believe the right
way to build a high rely highly reliable
application is to spread your workload
across multiple zones and what we've
seen is more and more customers are
actually doing that but the downside of
that and this goes back to the idea of
fairness again is if you did what we
suggested you do to have a great service
you're gonna be giving up discount
because now your machines are across
different zones and in fact maybe you're
actually not multi zone for some of your
things but for one reason or another you
decide to move to a different zone
perhaps you know sometimes not all of
our capabilities like a GPU for example
is available in every single zone and
you've started adding GPU usage and you
want to move zones we shouldn't be
penalized because you moved so we're
getting rid of that barrier and we're
moving su D to change so that it works
across all the zones in a region and
this will be rolling out pretty soon I'm
not gonna give an exact timeline now but
stay tuned there will be a blog
announcement about that and that's just
an example of we found a better way and
we want to bring that to you so I talked
about those inferred instances a minute
ago and you can imagine that when we do
that rollout these inferences will now
apply across all the zones in the region
and that's true except I'm happy to
report that I'm going to be able to
retire this slide pretty soon this is
one of the oldest diagrams I think we
have in our Docs it's kind of it's kind
of hard to read it takes a little while
to understand what it means it turns out
we have an even better idea so we're
gonna be getting rid of this
whole concept of inferred instances and
what we're doing instead is something
we're calling resource-based pricing so
we got a lot of feedback from customers
that you loved sustained use discounts
but that diagram is kind of hard to
understand and more importantly it's
very hard for you to model so a lot of
customers like to have their own system
be it a spreadsheet or another mechanism
that essentially calculates what our
billing system is going to calculate and
helps you accurately predict what your
spend is going to be maybe that's in
order to model a new application you're
deploying maybe it's because you're
considering a migration or maybe it's
just you like to have a different system
that keeps track of you know what you
think your bills should be so that you
can look for any anomalies and try to
understand them so it's very hard to
model so we're getting rid of it and
what we'll be doing instead is actually
a model it's very similar to what we
already do with committed use discounts
and I'll explain out a little bit more
in a second but essentially we're just
moving - it's all buckets of V CPUs and
RAM and we will look at all of your
usage across time and give you the best
sustained use discount you can so a way
to think of that might be low watermarks
essentially so I have a simple scenario
of what this is going to look like and
you can actually see there's
documentation up for this today but
again this will take a little while for
us to roll out one of the reasons we're
talking about it today is because we
recognize that this is a change to the
system and even though it's a change
that's completely in customers favor
it's different and so we want to talk
with customers explain what's gonna
happen make sure that you're all ready
so that when this shows up it's not a
shock and it's not a problem if you're
if you're expecting something different
on your bill so let's imagine this
scenario you're running a server you
happen to use one of our predefined
types our mainline type is in the
standard series so you have an n1
standard for it's 4 V CPUs and it's a
database server for your back-end it's
not dynamically auto scale but its size
according to what you expect your load
to me but you know that your CEO is
going on shark tank in a week and you're
expecting a big hit in traffic big jump
up and it's going to stay that way for a
while so you'd like to scale up to a 16
viii cpu database because you believe
that's what you're going to need
so how would sustain you supply in that
scenario so in the old model these two
instance types are different and just
assume for the moment that these are the
only instances you're running obviously
reality is a little more complicated but
let's say that there weren't really any
other 4v CPU instances that you were
running that would infer together with
your database and there weren't any
other 16v CPU instances that you were
running before you upgraded your
database well in that case if you
switched in the middle of the month
you'd only get the 10% tier of sustained
use discounts for each of those machines
in that month that's still it's kind of
nice but if you'd been running the
database all month you would've got 30%
so what if we just recognize that those
four cores are still four cores for V
CPUs and give you the max 30% on those
four and then give you the ten percent
on the other 12 and the next month you'd
get 30% on those 16 that's essentially
resource based pricing and it turns out
like I said we already count this way if
you're using committed use discounts and
in fact if you are using committed use
discounts then sustained use discounts
also already worked this way for any
usage that goes above your commitment
level because otherwise they wouldn't
play together nicely
but now we're just rolling this out for
everybody so all usage will see this so
if you'd like to know more the docks
link is up today there are a couple
things you should think about how this
fits with your model with your tools and
give you one example which is also
mentioned in the docs in more detail if
you're using bigquery billing export if
you're looking at the SKU to understand
what kind of machine you're using those
SKUs are going to disappear you won't
see an n1 standard for ski usage anymore
all it's gonna be is four units of V CPU
usage so it'll say something like V CPU
North America is one core there is
another field though called machine spec
it's a system tag that comes out that
tells you what that machine was
configured as so if you're looking for
detailed machine information you may
want to use that tag or you miss Ari
label or you may want to set up your own
labels to make sure that you have the
metadata you want in order to analyze
your billing and that's an example of
one of the reasons why we're previewing
this announcement so we like su D our
customers like su D but then they also
said hey it resets every month but I
know I'm gonna be running this workload
for twelve months or more can you do
like a mega sustain use discount like
just super sustained so we thought about
that for a little bit start talking to
customers and they said oh yeah also can
you do it without any machine size
restrictions and no zone restrictions to
get the discount I want to be able to
move things around and I don't want to
pay you all upfront because you know
cash flow so basically all the
flexibility and no restrictions can we
have that we said okay so that's
committed use discounts we introduced
this product last year again it was a
product that was in beta at the time
next happened and it went GA before the
end of the year essentially the concept
here is we give you the maximum
flexibility and the maximum discounts
that we can all we ask is that you tell
us if it's going to be one year or three
years that you're willing to sign up for
and the discounts vary between those two
when you tell us what region not which
is owned but we do have to do some
capacity planning to make sure that
those machines are there and then tell
us how many V CPUs and RAM you want and
now you'll see where this is the mirror
of the of resource based pricing for a
sustained use discounts it's just the
CPUs and RAM you use it however you want
that's it so thinking about those
principles I mentioned seems pretty
simple hopefully just a few decisions to
make that you should have a pretty good
idea of if you're looking at your
workload analyzing your bill one of the
nice things about this is because what
we find is that it has enough
flexibility that you can pre safely buy
up to the low watermark of your monthly
usage or usage over some period of time
that you believe is representative of
your needs and be pretty sure that all
of that is going to be used so we have a
number of
summers that tell us that they're
regularly seeing well about 90%
utilization on their on their committed
use discounts and it's very different
than some other discount products that
they've played with so the other thing
is if you're growing your deployment you
may want to come in and update that over
time to cover as much as your base usage
just makes sense so they're flexible you
can change shapes whenever you want to
the discounts not tied to a specific VM
you don't have to specify anything at
run time there's no tagging that says
this VM is a committed use discount this
one isn't the way it works is we do it
fairly and what fairly means is we
analyze this over the entire time span
of your usage and at any point in time
we take the first X V CPUs and the first
Y gigabytes of RAM that meet your
commitment and we apply committed use
discount across all of those if some VM
is temporarily contributing to that and
that VM stops and there's another one
that wasn't in in the consideration it
automatically gets considered so you're
always getting a maximum use of your
committed use discounts and then finally
the sustained us discount applies on any
usage that's above that threshold so
referring to that idea I mentioned a
minute ago of the low-water mark if you
know where your baseline is and you see
some usage over that you can rest
assured that that usage will still
qualify for sustained use discounts if
it is a significant enough period of the
month to qualify in a normal sense so
this was one of the quotes from our
launch article just to give you a sense
of what our customers thought about that
I think we kind of hit the mark I like
the last sentence the most
so another recipe last year in this talk
I would have said leverage preemptable
VMs is my favorite product is our best
product there's also the first very
first product that launched when I got
to Google so it might be biased but we
introduced this over three years ago
and the concept is really simple if your
workload can tolerate interruptions then
we will give you up to 80% off of the
cost of the VM for you to run at
preemptable VM
there's no auctions there's no bidding
there's no uncertainty except there is a
small chance usually around 10% that you
might get preempted with some of your
VMs earlier than the 24-hour window so
if your workload is prepared for that
this is a great option
now the reason I'm not saying VMs
anymore is because our customers have
told this I love this idea in fact I was
walking over here earlier customer was
telling me a lot of preemptable vs we
can't get enough of them we extended
this to our other resources so this is
now a general pricing concept in our
infrastructure layer of preemptable
resources you can also see it reflected
into higher level services that use
preemptable such as gke so beyond CPU
and RAM
we now have GPUs that you can get
preemptable cloud TP use you can get
preemptable and local SSD so what those
mean is if those are attached to a
preemptable VM you will get the
preemptable price on those resources and
the other rules around preemptable
shutting down early are the same now one
other thing I had a slide that I was
preparing for this I didn't quite get a
chance to throw it in we made an
announcement today which may have gotten
lost in the noise of many other
announcements that the cloud CPU prices
here are actually wrong there's a
promotional price going on right now
where that normal price is 450 and the
PBM price I believe is down to 135 so I
check that out if you're interested in
cloud CPUs but in general we continue
extending this and you may see it in
other places in the future so lastly and
we'll do a little QA think about tooling
how do you use all this stuff how do you
know that you're you're getting the
savings you hope for so the first key
and I put this one first not necessarily
because it's the first thing you're
going to use but it's the first thing
that I recommend that you do is run to
the cloud platform console when you
start setting up your project turn on
bigquery export now I will tell you this
comes with a small cost it is going to
store some data in bigquery and you have
to pay for that storage but the
advantage is if you turn this on right
away then even if you don't get around
to starting deep analysis of your costs
for a few months all that data will be
there in bigquery waiting for you so I
highly recommend you do that it gives
you much more information and there's a
bunch of tools that you can use the
leverage bigquery that will go much
better for you than extremely dense
spreadsheets which is what everybody
seems to use otherwise so I can't
underscore that enough second of all I
don't know what this picture is I was
thinking maybe it was like King Tut's
tomb or something in the different rooms
no actually this is a slide I stole from
the i/o 118 talk which I believe is the
one that already happened this morning
but that talk is all about how to
organize your resources using the
different features we have such as
organizations projects folders labels so
that you can do a really meaningful
analysis of how your utilization is
working so I definitely recommend
checking out that talk and it starts
like I said at the sort of two-person
shop and builds up to a large
organization multiple billing accounts
those kinds of things so it's great to
get a sense of how do I organize this so
I can analyze it later finding we have
some features around being able to set
budgets and in being able to get alerts
and notifications on those and then you
can have automated responses as well and
so this is a slide that I stole from the
i/o 103 talk which has not happened yet
so I would definitely recommend checking
out Stevens talk as well and there's a
rundown of all the different sessions
that talk more about all the different
billing techniques and to
that you can use to understand cost I
would also recommend which one is it
I believe it's IO 208 that has a
customer name vend hasta its Dale and
Dale from VIN dasa and they're very
funny guys and their talk is look at all
that as as described by them yesterday
look at all the stuff we did wrong
here's how we found it
don't do this so that's pretty
interesting sort of lessons learned
about analysis and billing so things
were they found oh look we were storing
10 terabytes of extra log data that we
didn't know about and the list goes on
you
[Music]